- All right, everybody,
let's squeeze in one more
story before we say goodbye.
I love this story.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
It's never too late to follow your dreams.
We hear that phrase all the time,
and sometimes it feels like empty words,
but not with this next story, y'all.
This is Shamone and she is a mama of four.
And two years ago, her
niece had a medical question
which Shamone tried to answer.
That interaction actually awakened
an old desire in her to become a doctor.
But instead of pushing
her dream back down,
this time Shamone acted on it.
Today, at the ripe age of 43,
Shamone is in her first
year of medical school,
which is so cool.
Let's get this boss mama in here.
This was a dream, right?
That just never went away.
- Absolutely.
Yes, absolutely.
You know, fear can sometimes
stop us from doing things.
And so, the MCAT is the test that we need
to get into medical school,
and it stopped me in
my tracks 15 years ago.
And now, in my second
semester of medical school,
it is very exciting.
- I love this.
I'm not only happy for you.
I'm happy that you're this
light to other people right now
sitting at home going, "Man,
I always wanna do this.
Why don't I do this?"
And we always feel like
we age out of something
and you can't age outta
something until you die.
So, keep doing what you wanna
do until that last breath.
So there's another important
reason that you're doing this.
Can you share that?
- Sure.
You know, COVID really was
tough for African Americans.
It was tough for everyone,
but we suffered even more.
And some of it has to
do with our hesitancy
in going to the positions,
going to our doctors.
And it's legitimate,
but my goal and my hope
is that I can kinda act
like a bridge between my
community and the medical field,
because the more we go to our physicians,
have a relationship with our physicians,
the better we can do
overall in our health.
- Absolutely.
You trust the physician with your health
and then you also can catch stuff in time.
That's the the most important thing.
Thank you so much, Shamone.
I'm so proud of you.
I don't even know you,
but I'm so proud of you.
You're so cool.
- Thank you.
- Congratulations on just
this awakening of this dream.
I'm so stoked for you.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(audience cheering)
And that's not all, ma'am.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot, pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor inspiring
people just like you, ma'am.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for $1,000 to help out with some bills.
(audience cheering)
- What? (laughing)
- Thank you so much, Shamone!
- No, thank you!
Thank you.
- All right, thank you
to all our guests today.
Ana Gasteyer, Phil Dunster, Rizz, Farrah,
and Devon Gilfillian.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.